right welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm delighted to be joined by amy
steele
amy works for the global recruitment
business
memorial bond and is an associate
director within the group
she runs the uk engineering contract
team amy has worked her way up the ranks
to this position within
nine years and now manages a team of
eight
and is the youngest director across the
group and achieved
director status in record time within
six years
amy thank you so much for joining me
thank you for having me it's great to be
here
really looking forward to this one um as
we've been chatting
always keen to get more and more female
leaders like you in recruitment
sharing your story so great and look
where i always like to start on this
podcast
is how you got into recruitment um
so just for context um have you only
worked for amore bond in the recruitment
world yeah okay of course
yeah so nine years in october you said
right okay cool so let let's just start
with how did amy end up working for
maury bond
okay yeah so i mean this is the only
company i've ever worked for so
graduated in 2011
did a degree in american studies in
history so
nothing related to the sector at all and
you know being completely honest i'd be
lying if i told you i always wanted to
go into recruitment as well because
i didn't even know what it was when i
graduated but um
i knew i'd probably go into some sort of
sales because i was always really
like money driven and when i did
graduate i never wanted to go down
the route like being a teacher or
anything like that which generally
history lends itself to
but i just knew i wanted to earn money
didn't know what i wanted to do just
knew i wanted to have a certain
lifestyle so
i spoke to my dad about it he works in
business so he's got
a pretty pretty commercially savvy he's
in this world
and said you know i really don't know
what i want to do but i want to earn
money and he was like you should go into
sales it'll toughen you up it'll give
you a really good grounding
so applied for some jobs online thought
they were sales roles and everyone that
was getting back in touch with me
were recruitment businesses so that's
when it came onto my radar so i
interviewed with a number of different
companies
in and around the manchester area but
yeah amore bond
really stood out to me i don't know what
it was there's just something about it i
just got this feeling when i
went there i just thought i can
definitely see myself in this company
and i think i just loved the values i
loved how competitive it was and
just got a great feel for the place and
then joined and i probably didn't really
know what recruitment was for a few
months after that either
just threw myself into it and just
adapted as i went so
yeah my first real job if you like was
the trainee recruitment consultant at
maurya bond
and yeah i've been there ever since
that's so interesting so what how old
was you when you joined there
uh 22. okay that's so interesting now
you're giving my age away
sorry sorry um okay just
just really quickly i've see i've been
to the memorial bond offices but like
what
what did the amore bomb because i'm sure
i'd be confident quite a few people know
the immoral bomb brand if they're up in
manchester whatever it's a big employer
in terms of
in the recruitment space up in
manchester what what
was the business like when you joined
like where was it in this journey
very different to how it is now so and
the amore bond was established in 2006
so yeah about five years after its
inception we had the manchester office
which is the office that we're in now
but we just had one floor
and there must have been maximum 20
people in there including
sales and back office staff and we'd
recently opened our amsterdam office at
that point as well and i think there's
about 10 people over in amsterdam
so a very very different company to what
it is now
and the values are the same the
principles are the same the markets are
the same but just on a much
smaller scale and now we've got pretty
much like half the building that we're
in is a maurya bond
we're actually moving to new offices in
uh well towards the end of the year to
an even bigger space because we've
outgrown it
and obviously we've now got the office
in clone and an office in singapore as
well so
when i joined i'd say total staff was
maybe around the 40 45 mark
now it's more like 120 125
so you might just post covered as well
so obviously there's been a few changes
recently so
sure okay so uh what was the environment
like then what what did you early on so
i'm always interested in the first
couple of years
like what what did amy do to ensure that
you didn't sort of get
um chewed up and spat out from
recruitment which
happens to a lot of grads right yeah
sure no definitely i think
you know the environment early on was
very structured like it is now
you know we do business development in
the morning we resource and find
candidates in the afternoon
we're very we still are now
we're far more advanced now from a
business intelligence perspective than
we were back then but we've always been
really really kpi and csf commercially
driven
so i think for me it was just a case of
you know as
a person i'm pretty resilient i i'm used
to being challenged you know because of
my background i've always been involved
in sports at
pretty highly competitive level and i
just applied the same
mindset and principles to the job i just
did what i was told every day
hit my targets every day and just worked
really really hard so
there was definitely times where i found
it difficult and times where i thought
i could give up here but it's just not
really in my nature and i think from
like a social perspective i settled in
really well and i made friends quite
quickly and
i think going to work around friends
every day is definitely something that
can keep you
keep you there and keep you um you know
engaged with the business
and because we were smaller as well and
there were people at different levels of
the business that i became quite close
to because back then there was literally
i was the third female in the office
okay third yeah it's obviously very very
we're a lot more 50 50 now by the time
it was very male driven
office so i became friends with two
girls that
both of them are quite senior in the
business so they were great role models
for me
i could see the money they were earning
the success they'd had so far
there was a similar age to me they'd
just not done the university bit
so i could see where i could be in a
couple of years if i you know what
what made them good what made them good
role models
just really great one one was really
great on process
did things by the book and the other was
a great business developer
and i think you know i i had i sort of
envisioned how i
wanted my life to be in terms of
earnings and what i would have and they
were living that already
so that was like pretty inspiring for me
that's
that's interesting um and just a
real quick one on that like
did you just go over and speak to them
did you just go over and ask for help
because i know it sounds really simple
and basic and
you strike me as someone that probably
just did that naturally but i think a
lot of people
some of the sort of interesting insights
that come from this is that some people
aren't
willing or don't want to look stupid and
go and ask
a top performer next to them say hi how
did you do that or
what are you doing differently so i'm
actually terrible at asking for help
really yeah it's absolutely terrible i i
don't i tell people the opposite all the
time i'm like make sure you ask for help
but
i'm really really bad at it so i think
the thing that's great about warrior
bond is
we have a really robust training program
and when you're seeing a consultant in
the business
part of that job even if you're not
managing people is to still mentor
and help people so when you join you
have people coming to you like can i
help you with this how are you getting
on with this
how's your day been you know not just
your manager but
your peers as well and that's very much
the case now but it was back then so
i wouldn't say necessarily i asked but i
got approached but what i would say is
in hindsight now i should have asked
more questions definitely
because um that's something i'm not
great at in general when it comes to
myself
how and last thing because i think again
this is a really interesting insight
like how
important do you think it is for
recruiters early on in their career to
actually really
make sure and focus on building internal
relationships
i think it's so important really really
important if you're having a really bad
day which let's be honest happens
i think the one thing that can help with
that and cheer you up there and then is
that is the people that you're working
with and
recruitment's long hours right we all
know that there's there's no real
getting
around that that's just a fact
especially in the earlier days
well actually i think i work longer now
than i did then
but um you know you spend so much time
with these people so
if you're not properly embedded into
that business forming relationships
you've not got that support network i
think it would make the job even harder
so
yeah anyone who's joining a business
throw yourself into it you know it means
pushing yourself out of your comfort
zone to get to know people
or socialize a bit more i would say do
it because i think that's a huge part of
it and
back to your question before about how
did i not get chewed up and start out
well i joined at the end of october
you know fast forward a month or two
it's christmas we have so many social
events going on the christmas party i
got taken to amsterdam
um you know loads of events lunch clubs
things like that and i just
i was so immersed in the culture that it
would have been impossible for me to
fail by that point because i just loved
it so much
yeah interesting okay so
just just the final bit for context then
so you've always worked in
contract recruitment right and obviously
as i introduce you i said engineering
but you've
you've worked across a few different
disciplines in the last
yeah so i originally started as a and
recruiting for contract design engineers
that was the market i was brought in to
do and i
naturally sort of moved a bit into
automotive so
automotive people will know if they've
been in the sector just absolutely
kicked off in around about like 2013-14
so my market went from design i picked
up an automated client
and i didn't just fill the design roles
i started feeling like project engineers
quality engineers things like that and
developed that account and then just
naturally started developing automotive
as
a bit of a market place which sort of
went against the grain as a business
were very much focused on disciplines
not sectors
um but because we're much smaller back
then with a lot more free reign than we
do now i was able to just sort of carve
that into a bit of a market and then
when i added to my team
i would then give people a discipline
within that sector so
i moved primarily into projects and
by sort of the last few years of my
career i wasn't i was literally just
placing project managers within like a
10 mile radius of coventry
didn't really deviate you know it didn't
really deviate beyond that i didn't need
to
like i knew everybody all the clients
knew me i pretty much worked with
everybody so
i was able to carve out that niche and
but as the team's grown we've had to
spread the risk more obviously the
automotive industry has really started
to decline
not just recently over the last couple
of years so as the team got bigger
strategically i needed to diversify to
create new markets
but also to spread the risk from a
sector over
to other sectors so um we now cover
design
projects quality manufacturing pretty
much the full project life cycle across
all
um stem engineering sectors so
automotive
aerospace defense rail and powered
energy nuclear
it's okay yeah cool got it right
so and and then just the final bit sorry
just for people listening so up until
2017 you was always billing right
and then for the last obviously a couple
of years you've been hands off and
really had to then learn this leadership
role where amy's not
actually billing right okay so first bit
how did the first couple of years go in
terms of amy get into the grips with how
to be
a good contract biller like how did you
do in the first couple of years
yeah so um i got off to a pretty quick
start actually
um i completely by accident not by scale
landed on a client and they didn't just
need one person they needed several
so made a couple of early placements um
my first year was good i got promoted to
consulting pretty quickly
i think it was in my fifth month um but
then
i think started to go a little bit wrong
for me actually my second year was a bit
of a disaster
and i basically just
i had so many dropouts and what i was
doing is i just listened to what i
wanted to hear rather than
what people are actually telling me so
you know the phrase like squarepad round
holes like that was the story of my life
and i got really frustrated and i used
to just blame the market like if your
market's too busy like you can't control
candidates actually
i was just trying to force things so um
my first year was great my second year
things started to store but once i took
a step back and was like i'm not
achieving what i want to hear
rather than blaming the market like i
need to look at myself
and i just got really passionate about
becoming the best
recruiter i possibly could be i just
hired somebody
and to mentor them i'd just become a
senior consultant after about
i think it's about 15 or 16 months and i
realized i had to really lead by example
and by
mentoring that person it made me become
better at the job
um and i just became really really
process driven
really tight with everything i was doing
from a candidate management perspective
and the key thing for me though is i got
really really passionate about business
development at that point
so i decided i wanted to have more
clients than anyone else like
i'm a very competitive person we
constantly review performance and who's
doing what
i was like yeah i want to have more
clients than anyone so i went on a bit
of a rampage
um towards the back end of my second
year on just winning business and
winning clients and
that was the real turning point for me i
think was my third year because i went
into the year
on around about five or six k running
weekly gp
um and it was in my third year that i
had done all the hard work really got
all these clients on board
and that's when it really took off for
me and i pretty much doubled my weekly
gp the following six months
while starting to build a team at the
same time okay but
definitely lessons learned in seconds
yeah what i'm keen just to break down
that amy
is that sort of moment of realization
that
actually for amy to be a better
recruiter to improve
i can't point the finger right yeah
because that's what you're saying and i
think that's such an important insight
and i went through that
myself and i've also experienced that
when
i was in a recruitment office and you
hear it right
[ __ ] candidates done this again or
clients done this or whatever it's it's
it's easy to blame right so
what i guess what helped you because i
think a lot i'm sure you've seen this
now when you manage it amy that
people get caught in that right and like
people
you can t you can shake them and go no
like you need to look at yourself but
sometimes it just doesn't sink
in so like what help what really helped
you overcome that mindset of
not being not taking responsibility and
accountability that actually
frees you to improve and to
become better yeah there's a few things
actually so i think for me
so there had to be like a point where i
hit where i thought
this can't continue so i'm really really
motivated by like
incentives and the trips and all the
good stuff that the company can offer
and
i actually hear i hit a trip i think
going to south france
and i had to drop out which meant i
didn't qualify so he got to go
and i was absolutely furious i was
absolutely devastated about it
and i was like really not happy about
this sat down with my manager
and he just basically just said i'm just
gonna be really straight with you
the problem is you and i think we have
to have that really difficult chat
because i'd always done pretty well
i guess i've gone under the radar a
little bit i wasn't the top former
but i wasn't underperforming so i got
under the radar in terms of these
challenging conversations i'd had
monthly business reviews which we do
every month
and they'd always been yeah you've done
all right like keep doing the same move
on
or you kind of drop out just look at why
change it there was nothing really like
too stern or alarming whereas things
were getting worse and then it got to
that point had that really difficult
conversation
and you know reflected on it and but you
know what he's right
i am like not here to be average i'm
here to be the best and
if i don't start looking at how i can
improve then i'm never going to be the
best so i think that realization that
difficult chat
and then also i started like doing more
self-development work
so i don't know if you've heard of the
book what's great yeah what was that
good to great to great yeah i absolutely
loved that book and
i i still didn't pin it out of it now
but i read that and
that was just a game changer for me like
there was so much good stuff that came
out of that
um in terms of like mindset
and change and just trying to be better
and why
people like why good is the enemy of
great basically like you can carry on
being good
if you just keep doing what you're doing
but you'll never be great
and that just like really rang true for
me because
i was good and i was doing fine but i
wasn't fulfilling my potential
and i was getting frustrated with that
and then i read that book and just so
much stuff like resonated with me
um and yeah i guess i just tried i just
took a step back
and decided yeah i'm not here to be
average i'm not earning what i want i've
not
progressed as quickly as i want and i'm
gonna do something about it i love that
that that's awesome so if i'm listening
right now amy and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm that person i'm i'm i am the
way that amy's describing how she was
in terms of the person that you was at
that point in your career
what would just be like your go-to like
right really think about this ask
yourself this question go and read this
book i don't know what would be your
sort of just go-to
place to try and encourage someone to
take that
step back just to run that off i mean i
think it's
really hard right to look at yourself
and think i need to do better it's me
like no one wants to admit
that do they so i guess my advice would
be like
there's no there's no failure in that um
you know
it's it's fine to accept that you you
can be better and you can change things
and i think it's just giving yourself
that time to reflect so you're feeling a
bit disengaged feeling a bit frustrated
especially at the moment like
let's be honest it's been a pandemic
like it's not been fun for everybody
no one's where they want to be right now
and
so and it's okay to take that step back
and think you know what can i do
differently
it's not a failing it's just a change
and it's a shift and honestly like we've
always had this phrase at a maury bond
which is always your fault
so if something goes wrong it's always
your fault it's always within your
control now
we know it's not always the case but we
have that mindset on the basis that
that's how you improve so i think just
tell yourself like
it's weird but like say like it is
always my fault what can i do
differently
and just i guess take a step back and
re-look and analyze what you're doing
longer term you'll you know you'll thank
yourself for it yeah
amazing love that so next part that i
was just really keen just to get your
thoughts on because it sort of
it seemed like a really important moment
to you
pushing on in your career and it's
probably if i'm honest the area where
most recruiters feel like they need to
improve
or want to learn and develop and that's
business development
and that's client acquisition i'm sure
you've seen this now
managing people so you were just saying
before we went into that around the
you decided that you're going to be the
best recruiter you can be and you want
as many clients as pos possible that's
going to enable you to reach the goals
that you
have for yourself yeah what how did amy
still approach
business development that you think
really enabled you to
hit your business development targets
and achieve what you wanted to
yeah so i think the first bit is to from
a planning perspective i got really
really religious with planning the night
before so
i was always a bit guilty of just like
banging equip plans together running a
search on the system
there wasn't a huge amount of strategy
behind it and so instead i just
actually mapped out companies i thought
we'd do automated let's properly map it
out let's split them into different
sections look at locations and
just make sure i'm adding more data more
qualitative data
so i can have a better conversation with
that person and
so the planning element became a huge
part of my daily structure so i would
always do it before
i left but the difference was i used to
do it like my last job of the day
i restructured and started doing a four
o'clock instead so i do an hour from
four till five
rather than starting it like six half
six where i was already a bit frazzled
like ready to go home my brain wasn't
fully operational anymore and i just
restructured started doing it earlier
and
it was just a much better quality plan
which meant that the calls the following
day
must mean the right people about the
right things
and and then beyond that it was all
about meetings for me
i got i felt one felt so much more
comfortable in person than over the
phone
and cold calling up was fine i didn't
mind it in the end like i would say i
loved it i wouldn't say i'm the best at
it i was consistent with it
and i knew what i was talking about but
for me it was all about meetings i knew
if i could get in front of a client
i would come away with business of like
contract jobs or pipeline or future
excuse
exclusivity so normally we target all
everyone on ten meetings attended a
month
my target was 20. 20 meetings a month
yeah yeah
because you've gone through that one no
no it's okay
because that's what got results for me
so yeah you so you recognize yeah so you
recognize that if you
you recognize yeah more face-to-face
meetings meant the
more chance of you winning business or
formerly relationships
what the only thing that i was gonna ask
sorry to button but
um was around basically what
what is the recipe or what do you think
gave you the best chance of looking in a
meeting
so what in terms of booking the meeting
just like
so if i'm listening to this i'm like
right okay well actually you know what
amy is completely right i need to get
more face-to-face or i need more zoom
video calls
yeah what what's what's been your sort
of secret
source of that or what's just really
worked for you in terms of if i call you
right now and my objective is right how
can i get a meeting
yeah what's really worked for you yeah
sure so i think it's really important to
lead with the benefit to the client
of any sort of meeting because
ultimately
so many people fall into the trap and i
hear it all the time on sales for like
selling the benefit to yourself not to
to the client so i think it's really
important to know the benefits of the
client of meeting you
and that there's various different like
benefits to them
you know if we see the site we can
represent them more and effectively
on the marketplace when they're hiring
for them it will give us a greater
understanding of what they do so we can
screen and select
more appropriate candidates for them and
in terms of working together and
building a partnership it's really
important that we get that face time to
get to know each other
and and i think clients like meetings as
well it shows that you're taking it
seriously
and and you know when you're on site you
can see multiple people as well so it's
not like
you're driving down to coventry or
whatever for one person like you can go
down for the day and see like eight to
ten people so
it's a really good use of your time and
i think as long as you leave with the
benefit
and i think as well like conviction in
the pitch you know
again here people and i probably did it
say like do you think it'd be a good
idea if it's like no
it would be a great idea for us to meet
because xyz
benefit you know when are you available
next tuesday or wednesday and like
alternative close it so
i used to have them one day a week on
meetings so every tuesday was my
meetings day
so i used to already have it mapped out
in my calendar so i'd ring a client
pitch so i'm actually coming down to the
area
next tuesday are you available you know
certain time yeah afternoon yeah
and if they weren't i'd be like okay no
problem well now that we have to because
they come every week
and name drop all the clients that
you're working with like if you're not
working with them just name drop them
if you are then it's even better and and
that's part of working in this niche you
know you get to know your clients and
your candidates and
you know you they need to be dealing
with you yeah i love that
so key distinction there anyone
listening and what i wanted to highlight
from what i got from that amy was
um benefits of for them
not for you right and what you mean by
that is if i call you right now i'm
going look
i'm a specialist there so i'm great at
this blah blah blah the benefits of
working with me well actually no it's
look
amy we should meet because this is going
to mean all the benefits for you
right so i think that's the key
distinction there because it's easy to
go to sell yourself which is part of it
right but
that initial part to get that meeting is
why is that worth their time
right and that isn't because you're the
best it's because this is how
we're gonna i'm gonna be able to help
you better if we do that um
that's really interesting so just the
the other part of this amy because it's
a question i get all the time and you've
mentioned it a couple of times
um around this organization of your time
managing your desk
all these things it seems like you've
been on a journey with this and you've
really refined this
in your billing days it seems like um
and it's one of the most
common things that i get so i guess if
you think of what amy's
daily routine or weekly routine schedule
was at the beginning of your
billing career by the time when you was
hitting big figures
yeah what what did the sort of the
perfect week look like
what what how did how was your day and
we want detail here because people
want to know how a recruiter plans out
their day
holiday yeah sure i mean i don't know if
you've ever heard this phrase before but
like you think you're organized until
you start working in recruitment
then you realize you're really really
not so i always thought i was great
and really organized but i clearly
wasn't so yeah so back yeah back in the
day when i was running my own desk so i
had a pretty
like strict regime like at least like
used by my day like by the hour in the
end so
i'm getting early i'm a bit of an early
bird so i usually get in seven seven
thirty jump on check my emails
deal with anything that is coming
overnight it's pretty urgent i'd have my
day planned from the night before
already so if there was any
thing that had come in overnight like
candidates would send emails
with references on to take could add
them to the system get them on my plan
and then i would log on to and do a bit
of job spotting so i don't know if
you're familiar with that but basically
go on to the job boards look at for the
recruiter's advert see if i could work
them out
put them on my plan bring them myself
yeah of course
do that or whether that's just us maybe
giving away a bit of a trade d for that
i used to do that sure it's quite common
but yeah okay good
good yes i used to do that um first
thing as well so
i got really like like passionate about
job spotting like if there was ever a
job that went up in my market contract
job
i would want to know about it and i did
that every day so i've got on top of it
so it didn't ever be maybe one or two
new ones a day
try and work them out get them on the
plan and
and then i would basically start um
i'd always try and be on the phone
before eight o'clock so at eight to
eight thirty
i would jump on the job board and bring
candidates who put their cv up the night
before so just to try and get to them
first for my live jobs
just before any of the recruiters that
are on the phone to them and
so i'd do that and my goal was always to
have at least one cv to job
by 9 a.m which was when i moved on to bd
so sort of 8 to 8 30 to stroke 9 o'clock
depending on how many jobs on and what i
was working
ring candidates qualified and screen
them hopefully prep and send at least
one cv to job
then nine till 11 30 was
purely business development so cold
calling
following up my leads speaking to my
clients i was working a job for
taking references and then mmc course
and the key part here is the button the
key part here is that amy still
planned this session a day before yeah
four four to four four o'clock the day
before yeah yeah
of course everyone was already on my
plan all the managers i was going to see
yeah because i
feel like that's key isn't it that
that's the key yeah that's cute
so important like i used to hate it save
us juice beyond a day of meetings and
whatever reason they got cancelled and
i'd come in i had no plan i used to just
hate it
i feel all over the place so yeah so
that that two and a half hour session
i'd shut my emails down
i would be like no one talk to me get in
the zone
and just like absolutely power through
and that's probably because cold calling
didn't come
like totally naturally to me at first i
got pretty nervous about it which
giving them quite a confident person is
quite unusual um
and i did i literally used to call call
people to get a meeting because then i
knew it
in person i'd be fine that's how i
started to when i was doing my bd
yes obviously you want to take a job and
get a job that's the goal number one
but in my head psychologically i'd just
say to myself you just ring into book
meeting
you're just going to [ __ ] me yeah
yeah but the result of that
was that i got really confident i had
good conversations and my beauty really
improved but that for that like two hour
period i literally just shut off
no one talks to me this is what i'm
doing okay um
then at half 11 i would break off and
i'd spend 30 minutes following
up on everything that i've done over
that period so
any thank you for your time emails any
terms that needed to be sent over
any like administration diarizing my
meetings so
i'd get all that done straight after so
as i'm doing my business development
i always always do this and definitely
recommend it make a to-do list
so rather than doing it there and then
so if i spoke to somebody and they said
yeah i'll meet you at this time
send me some details rather than putting
the meeting in and then sending the
details
i would literally just record it all on
the system
put it on the to-do list and then at the
end yeah love it love it so you tie it
tight
all together yeah there's no disruption
in you focusing on bd
then half 11 till 12 is like right i
need to follow up what admin yeah yeah i
love that okay
what happened to 12. yes in 12-1 so
at that point we would either have like
training usually in the diary
or i would prep and send um like a
client
like like rtm so like a bit of like a
mass email with a cv on
or and i would get my jobs ready to work
for the afternoon so i'd create
send another candidate email out to try
and get more interest
repost any new jobs and adverts any job
admin basically
to get a really good list of candidates
ready for the afternoon session
and and then i don't know if this is
going to be a great tip or not i never
really take lunch
i use like go grab my lunch but then i
just carry on okay
because i always thought like there's no
point me being sat there for an hour
like
reading the daily mail when i could just
be working yeah
i don't think there's ever a good time
to read the daily mail for an hour
i was always going to say you do you
yeah when when do you eat i mean for me
personally um i like
i don't really enjoy eating in the
morning because i actually just feel
more focused and just more
light when i haven't eaten personally
and then i'll i'd normally eat my first
meal
at one whatever but okay that's
interesting exactly the same i'm
terrible i never have breakfast so i
have i make myself like
like a nutribullet yeah
yeah okay get you ready for the
afternoon jobs get yeah
and then what are you doing for one to
go yeah so one till two is like
technically lunchtime but i'd go grab
some lunch jump back on maybe 20 past
half past one
and then i just start working jobs so um
i would
prioritize based on the urgency and
commitment from the client so
if i had interview slots available the
following day or
within that week that would be my
priority so one thing
i probably missed actually when i'm
doing my business development every
client i'm working a job for
i speak to them every day no matter what
to give them an update on my progress
and to find out the status of the job
have they got other interviews what's
changed
just so i'm really clear on where i
spend my time because
what i want to do is spend a whole
afternoon working on the job
to then bring the client and find out
i've actually refilled it or it's been
pushed back
or whatever so i would just check in
every morning is it still alive do you
still want to interview tomorrow how
many people do you want to see from me
today
and like treat it as more of a
partnership i think people like
put clients on pedestals and you've got
to remember like you're working with
them not for them and
if they give you a vacancy ultimately
they're giving you work to do you know
they're not giving you money at you have
to fill that job
and until it's filled we don't make
anything so you know it's going to be on
my terms
as much as it is theirs and i think
having that mindset allowed me to get
really clear
on my prioritization on the vacancies
that i was working
because i just i'd learned the hard way
from wasting my time on countlessly yeah
that didn't go anywhere i think that's
really smart man because i think there's
that sort of
i don't know if it's fear but that sort
of internal dialogue of the i don't
recall that crime i forgot nothing to
update them on or
i haven't got this amazing candidate to
tell them about but actually it's
just as much in your interest to find
theirs to find out okay what's the
latest what's going on where are you
with things and that's going to help you
put definitely the right resources so
are you just working candidates one till
four then
yeah pretty much just working jobs all
afternoon so
really again really high intensity and
lots and lots of outbounds anyone i do
get on the phone even if they're not
looking
get names from them if people they know
people they're working with and
and all and also again i used to always
say like who do you know that's looking
and there's a lot of no one
but you just have to reframe that
question you know who do you work with
that could do this job because then
you're still getting names it's like
they're probably gonna question that i
get that but like who do you know and
i'll call them
and just getting names and constantly
trying to increase your your candidate
network
and and then prepping and sending the
cvs over
and i usually would try and put a quick
call in again at that point sell them in
over the phone see if i can get an
interview booked for them
there and then and rather than you know
just sending them yeah
to see um okay what i like to do with my
clients is agree
times to speak each day so one client of
mine that i've done a lot of work with
over years we speak at half-life every
day when i'm working a job for him
and that's that's the time he makes it
free i make it free
it's really simple he always answers
when i ring i talk about the people i
found that day and we book them in
um not found them why i've not found it
okay
and then four till four to four five
you're planning the next day
four to five sorry yeah planning for
business development planning adding
data
and doing a bit of research and then
at five o'clock until 5 30 we do a group
close every day so everyone in the
office reports back
on what they've done so far yeah and
their action plan and then half five
onwards
back on the phone working jobs finals
love it so let's just run this off right
so i know that we were talking before
like um so what in terms of like
billings wise obviously you're a
contract recruiter just for contents in
your own markets but
like for me i i don't want to just
assume i know the answer is this but
just for context like
i know you said that you um you won top
biller a couple of times within the
business like what was your best year
so my best year was 4
000 uh no sorry 493
000 and i was furious because it wasn't
have you broke the 500k mark before
no no okay i know i know to be honest
though like
because i was building a team i'm making
an excuse here because those buildings
at the same time like
if i'd not built a team maybe i could
but i wanted to manage
so other things were important to me as
well okay but yeah
but consistently 480. yeah around that
okay right
cool so the reason why i just wanted
that for context
how important was
amy still having a process
so because like everything that we're
talking about now it may sound a bit
like oh [ __ ] that that just seems way
too structured blah blah blah but the
punchline is
how confident would amy still be if you
didn't have that structure or didn't
have that plan
do you think you'd build those numbers
definitely not
absolutely not because on top of this
because i was building my team i had to
get even more organized that was my
typical day when i was only responsible
for myself
i got to the point where i'd actually
start recruitment at 4pm every day
because i was just helping other people
so
you know you have to be organized you
get so much more out of your time and i
think you have to be strict with it as
well you've given yourself
two hours to do a task even if you've
not achieved your objective
you still have to move on because you've
got other stuff and then stuff will get
backlogged as much as that
have you ever heard of the book eat that
frog
uh which is like do
do the things that you have to or don't
want to do first
get it away yeah i i it's a really short
book i definitely recommend it it's i
get people in my team to do it when they
struggle with time management and things
because
it's really really simple like theory
but it's yeah just like make a list
get the urgent and hard task out of the
way and just carry on
so yeah i think no structure is so
important i mean if you speak to any of
my team now like they'll tell you
all i do is bang on about structuring
your time
being on top of your business being
organized because i think it just makes
such a difference to your output and
when you've got direction you're gonna
get more done
and you're gonna be more productive and
you know i don't want people working 12
13 40 nowadays you're going to burn out
you know if you can get it done in 11
hours or 10 hours like that's so much
better and you're going to go home
switch off
get a better night's sleep and start
again because
you know you're not wasting time and i
feel like
when you have that structure you can
leave that office
or there's more of a chance of amy
leaving that office going i've had a
good day today or
because there's nothing worse than
leaving that recruitment office and
going right what the [ __ ] did i do today
you know and
normally that's because you didn't have
a structure or whatever so
okay so the next part that i want to
talk to you about amy is so you're
you're someone that
has thrived in a very competitive
environment
and obviously yeah moribund's a big
business is there's a lot of people in
here
a big part of this in terms of your
success clear process and learning what
works for you being disciplined etc
um why do you think that amy's been the
person that's been able to
achieve things like the road to
directorship quite
quicker than other people why have you
been the person that's
managed to get your hands on the
opportunities to be a director to have
more management responsibilities just
more of an opportunity to progress
basically everyone has to progress their
career and progress then professionally
personally whatever right but out why
was it not
the person next to you amy do you think
yeah it's a really difficult question
um no i think i think i know why so
firstly i think the thing to mention is
you know i
have literally committed to this company
in this job like as a
number one priority and i've made a lot
of sacrifices along
the way in order to be where i am like
particularly in the early days when i
was 22 23
my friends were all going out a lot like
in the week and i was
literally sat in an office not earning
any money at this point either
and working around the clock in the
blind hope and faith that what i was
being told about recruitment
would come true and so you know and i've
continued to work really really hard
like my job is
my priority and you know i i have the
life that i want outside of work now
because of the the incoming platform
that it's given me and i do what i want
but
my job has always always come first and
you know i've just worked
really really hard consistently though
and
i think the other bit is probably just
around well
training and development i'm massive on
self-development and training i'm always
trying to get better
and really passionate about being the
best and being good at things
and but i think ultimately i just got
this
burning desire to be successful no
matter what like
there's nothing that's going to stop me
have you cultivated that or is this
something that you think your parents
has impacted or have you always had a
chip on your shoulder what where
they from my upbringing so my bit of an
unusual brings my dad was a professional
cricketer okay so i've grown up in an
environment of like
success in sport and i did sport from
from the age of three i did gymnastics i
competed nationally i then went into
athletics competed internationally
i've always been like
challenged in terms of i've been in an
environment where like it's all about
winning
like that that's just who i am like i'm
one of those awful people that ruins
everything because they're so
competitive like nothing is fun anymore
like
i have to make it a competition it's a
really horrible trait of mine
but you know and then my so my dad was
creator and then he
and when he retired which he did in his
early 30s obviously the money back then
wasn't like it is now so he basically
had to
like restart again and went and did um a
degree and then a masters in business
and then has
gone on to set up his own like companies
and been pretty successful and i think
it's just like
innate in me like to be a success and
it's for myself but it's also i guess
part of it is like i like
to be seen to be successful too you know
i want people to
be quite inspired and want to do the
same and
i think it's yeah it's just been in me
since since i was little way off the way
i've grown up yeah
i i want to talk to you about women and
and being a female in recruitment
because i think there's an interesting
link there around your priority and
sacrifice you had to make and i'll bring
that link but just
just quickly because i want to make sure
i ask you this
i think how have you so with that in
mind what you just said around you being
competitive and you just had this
burning desire
yeah have you had to get better at
being fulfilled or when you like because
the the hard part of that amy kramer if
i'm
wrong and if you don't feel this that's
cool but like
when is it ever good enough or when have
you ever been good enough it's not
that that's that well that's what i mean
so i feel like
the reason why i'm mashing this is
because a lot of people always
talk about being a top biller aspiring
right right and i think there's this
interesting other conversation that
when you so like amy reached this top
bill of status
then all of a sudden you've got this
whole new thing to deal with is like
okay well if i'm not the top biller
again what am i
and i'm not and like you can be really
hard on yourself and that's a whole i
know it sounds like
which is done 480k so it can't be that
bad but actually
there's a whole nother thing internally
that you've got to deal with there do
you get what i'm in
absolutely and you know what
interestingly that was probably the
hardest
time in my career was at the end of 2017
so that was like my final year as a
biller i had a team of 14 people i'd
just been promoted to
associate director in september our
financial year ends the end of november
and that was like my cut-off point it
was like i'm gonna walk away from
billing i'm just gonna focus on
management i have to do it from like
a board level it was like you know you
can't be a villain still you know
you need to expand this team and you
know it's not your job anymore and
probably the hardest thing for me
was going from being the leader that led
by example
do this because i'm doing it to
something having to manage
people without being that like role
model and that was really challenging
for me
whilst also taking a step back from the
limelight if you like and yeah not
because i wanted that line like
necessarily it was morbid for myself
because you start to question and doubt
like am i as good at management as i was
at
being a leader another billing leader
and you know then it was a really
challenging year 2018. and we we didn't
perform like 2017 was the peak of my
billing and we won team of the year
internally
in the business so it was like
absolutely like high
and in 2018 it was really tough you know
automotive started to climb we had to
diversify
as the team got bigger you start dealing
with more problems
it was a really challenging time for me
and i really started to question like
can i even do my new job like i don't
even know if i can and you know you feel
like you've lost the dressing room a bit
at times because
managing people when you're not doing it
yourself is a lot harder
i think or i did find it that way and
so yeah it was it was really really
tough and it took me a lot longer to
adjust
than i would have expected it probably
took me over a year
before i was fully comfortable with the
fact that you know
that's not my job anymore and yeah
that's that's tough yeah
yeah i totally get that um and just
final thing on this because i think
again it's an important discussion
what what's been your uh you don't have
to give me all the details but the
reason i want to talk about is
i think um there's this really so
there's this really interesting
conversation around how many people tell
recruiters
or give advice or guidance on what to
spend their money on
right like outside of work yeah just
because i think
like you talking about young amy right
that you sacrificed he wasn't out as
much i think
look there's this as i think we
obviously a lot of recruiters are
motivated from external things right and
that's right and you said you was
motivated by incentives and all these
things right
yeah when 24 year old amy is is earning
a lot of money
like have you gone through london from
that any advice for people on that
because
i think it's important yeah i mean i
went out and bought porsche
which was a huge mistake because it
can't be unfortunate
so definitely don't do that especially
not with the new benefit and contacts do
not do that
no do you know what it was always a big
goal of mine to get a porsche yeah i was
able to get it on the
car scheme and it was amazing but
wow did it cost me money yeah but yeah
no i think you know what it's a lot of
naturally a lot of recruiters and why
they go into recruitment is because
they're quite really motivated
and you know often relatively
materialistic in terms of like
holidays clothes bags shoes and stuff i
like
um but you know you see it quite a lot
all the time and
when i look back i've blown a lot of
money absolutely but i've had a great
time along the way but
now i've you know i've got a lot that
i'm proud of you know i bought my house
um three years ago so a really lovely
aria wilmslow and cheshire
always been a big goal for me you know
to buy a house like that
and you know got a range rover which was
always a goal as well much more economic
than before which i have to say
so yeah i think advice it's difficult
because everyone's different you know
and i've got people that work for me
that just like
spend all the money on rubbish but that
keeps them happy and i've got others
that are huge savers
and i wouldn't really want to tell
people like what to do but like
do i think you've got to reward yourself
right you're working really hard
yeah you're dealing with a lot of stress
you're getting let down all the time by
people because you know that's your
product
and you know with spending money on
certain things makes you happy and
that's why you do it and do it if saving
it to buy something big does as well
then fine you know
i think it's all right i i just think
there's a funnel like you talking about
how you've invested in yourself
self-development i just think
there needs to be a conversation on
financial education as part of that that
isn't aim you spend your money like this
is
hey by the way amy when i was when i did
what you did this is what i learned
and learned this if you wanted to take
that what you want but i think there
there should be
i feel like more conversations around
consider this when you get that big
paycheck do you know absolutely 100
yeah there's a real lack of education on
it and you know you've got 22 23 year
olds
on six figure salaries not knowing what
to to spend the money on and i've got
examples of that in my team now so i see
it firsthand and
yeah i think there's definitely a big
gap there you know how to invest money
where to save money
you know you don't get taught that sort
of stuff in school really either
and you know recruitment recruitment's
probably the only profession maybe
outside of football where you can be you
know in your early 20s
on that sort of money probably or maybe
other sales roles but
um we we like to do a lot of work on
well we do do a lot of work on goal
setting
and getting people really clear on their
goals not just their materialistic goals
but like
their life goals as well and how that's
going to make them feel and really about
investing in themselves and their
well-being
so we try to provide as much structure
and direction as we can
by doing that because it's not just
about you know the money side is it it's
you know
you're elevated in terms of the
responsibility that you've got to
and i think channeling that in the right
way is really important
as well um we we do a lot like from a
training perspective obviously we work
with you
which is great and we have you know
other external trainers so the company
invests a lot
in that side of things but we probably
don't encourage people to do it
themselves enough so something to think
about yeah interesting
right so females in recruitment
yeah so so where i've where i put the
link together so why
um it was in like the first 50 episodes
of this podcast i did like a woman in
women in recruitment week okay okay and
one of the real common threads that i
saw speaking to
to females like yourself so you when
you're telling me that your
number one priority was work yeah right
and you put all your eggs in that basket
work your absolute socks off right which
is a big reason as to why
you've got to where you've got two and
the two things you have right yeah so i
think the common thread that
i kept hearing was if i'm a female
i can find myself at this cross junction
where it's like do i want to raise a
family
yeah or do i have to give up my career
right and i think there's this
interesting like
internal battle some females may not
know that they don't want to have a
family right
but a lot of females do and there's this
sort of internal
like yeah struggle with like absolutely
yeah and i think that
from what i saw i feel like from the
conversation stuff and i was having a
conversation with
um a female recruit today called ellie
and this is one of the things that she
really wanted me to speak to
females about who have went and actually
formed the family because it's something
that she knows that she wants but
actually
is that going to mean that all this hard
work that i put into my recruitment
career is that going to suffer and did
you get what i mean so like
have you been through that what's what
absolutely i mean i've not i've not got
um a family and i've not got any
immediate plans to have a family but
it's definitely something that i
think about and i know that other
females in the business have thought and
asked about as well and i think
any female working in sales there's
always going to be that element of like
if i take
time out what is the impact of that
going to be on my business and on my
progression because
it is different for us like it is you
know even if we have a baby and then
take three months out
which is like the minimum probably it's
still a long time in recruitment
so it's a huge challenge and i don't
think we necessarily have a solution to
it yet
what i can say though is that you should
never ever sacrifice something like that
for a job like it's your family at the
end of the day it's the most important
thing
but i think companies are becoming more
and more equipped
to deal with that and provide a platform
to allow females to go and
you know have a family take time out and
return without feeling like they've lost
too much ground so
it's definitely been a huge agenda point
for us maurya bond so
we've recently launched um a women's
network within the company called ascend
so and that's been in the making for a
while
but has been fast-tracked a little bit
because we're doing a lot of work on
diversity inclusion but also because
it was becoming more and more apparent
that we've got more girls in the
business now which is great
but what that means is the the
question's coming up a lot more you know
what is the
what's the the policy when it comes to
this because there's not really i'm the
only one when you say policy you mean if
i leave and have children
like yeah what happened like how do i
come back what yeah what does it mean
how long have i ever got off
what do i get paid do i still get my
commission like loads of questions and
you know what if i've got a team do i
don't have to hand them over like
there's just loads of questions isn't
there and
i think um it's really highlighted that
we we don't have a set policy nor do i
think we should have one because
everyone's an
individual but clearly now we have more
women in our business this topic is
going to come up more and more and
i'm the most senior sales female in the
company
um i'm the only sales manager if it's a
female in the company
and i've not been through it so there's
no one there that's that role model
so um you know we we've launched this
network and we had the
the launch session last week and a
really common theme that came up was
this
so it's something that we're now going
to prioritize and tackle because
i don't want anyone to feel like their
job
or career is going to be sacrificed or
held back in any way having a family
i certainly don't want to feel that i
think i think the first thing which i
love about that amy is that
i think there could be nothing worse if
you're if you're an environment and
you're
yeah you're at that sort of crossroads
or you feel like you need to start
thinking about it and you
you really feel like you can't talk
about it because i think i think that
that's the most important thing that if
you feel like you can't talk about you
don't talk about it there's no potential
solution
or whatever right but the fact that you
guys are actually going
right what could this look like how
could that be blah blah blah gives you
then an opportunity like right we should
think about getting
this in place or whatever right so much
of it is about communication because
you know people need to be able to feel
comfortable to have that conversation
without somebody jumping to conclusions
and thinking ultimately are you going to
leave and have a baby next month like
it's not about that it's more about
future planning isn't it and and that's
why we create this network
so much of it's an education piece for
the male managers as well around
communication
and as a business because we want more
females to progress
and you know we that's a big goal for us
and
if having more of a platform or more of
a support structure in place for
women who have a family and then return
needs to be there for that to happen and
you know that's what we're going to do
yeah so why don't we just talk a bit
more about this then so
so because i think you broke it down
into three areas which i thought was
really great so
the purpose of this one is to actually
have a place where as a female
recruiter in a big business i can go to
and talk about
things that maybe if i was to speak to
jeff next to me may not
be able to fully understand or see it
from my point of view right so that's
great
so what were the other purposes of this
yeah so well
the key things we've because we've got
four offices and some are very
so the uk office is like 50 50 females
males
i'm there as well as like a leader so
very very
comfortable with the whole female male
dynamic whereas some of the other
officers in the business maybe like one
or two females so
they were feeling a little bit
disconnected from the group so we
created a stand really to connect and
support all the women across the
different offices
and and to provide networking
opportunities with
senior role models in the business but
outside of the business too
and you know with the goal of attracting
retaining and progressing
more women in a more ebony and that's
the really key bit is
is that and we you know it's all about
progression yeah but
how do we get to that point and that's
why we took it right back to the
beginning and it's like well we've got
to attract more women first
and then we've got to retain them and
then we've got help and progress
how do you feel we can do that as an
industry do you think yeah so
i think a lot of it will come down to
the internal recruitment process
so getting involved and in the interview
so the females coming into the office
for an interview
having 10 minutes with one of the other
the women there one of the girls that
are just as quick 10-minute chat about
what it's like
and having programs like this within an
organization so people feel you know
comfortable and i think linkedin and
social media is a huge part of that as
well like celebrating women in
recruitment
and celebrating success creating
awareness around it being pretty like
visual with different schemes and
incentives that are going on
just so more women can get into the
industry
i think it's quite old-fashioned that
people think it's male-dominated
i think it probably was at one point but
i honestly don't think it is now
i just don't think we're we create
enough awareness around the fact that
if the shift is has taken place yeah no
you're right and i think
as i've said to you before this like for
whatever reason if you were to look at
the last 30 episodes there's definitely
more
guys on yeah i think yeah and i just
think
like i don't know always like if i was
to speak to
a female about coming on the first thing
they said to me is like and if i was to
say look
at me how open it would be to get
involved normally again i'm just
generalizing here but
normally they might go i'm not sure how
much value that i'd bring and i think
it's that part that we were talking
about
before we started where i love the fact
that you're willing to sort of
get on the soap box and go look this is
what i've achieved i've worked hard for
it what i've done
like not in an egotistical way but yeah
actually i think that's important
for females to have role models and see
other people celebrate their success and
not be
i don't know i don't it's embarrassment
but it's i don't know if it doesn't come
natural to you or whatever
naturally yeah it's not natural to sort
of talk like yourself necessarily
i mean that's what obviously i said to
before i started but i think really it's
just awareness and it's just
it's about support like i think you know
from a communication perspective and in
terms of
how you know we're programmed we we tend
to be more on the
like not emotional but like we we tend
to be more on the emotive side of things
so like communication with the male
manager
sometimes can be a bit cold and a bit
harsh and that's how they communicate
their male stuff maybe sometimes you
need to be a little bit more
understanding
with a female that's something that when
i
speak when i manage my team i do adopt
my style based on the personality
of the person um that i'm that i'm
dealing with you know male or female and
i think just maybe there's just a bit of
an awareness of that
and but the more women we get in then
you know
the more women that will progress longer
term so that attraction piece is just
huge i think
massive and that's why i really wanted
to come on today as well because
you know if there are other like female
recruiters out there or people
thinking about getting women thinking
about getting into recruitment but
aren't sure like
i'd really just love to encourage you
all to do it because it's been an
absolute game changer it's changed my
life so yeah i think that's amazing so
happy i did it yeah
so look before we finish what what i'd
just love to get your thoughts on amy
because i feel like this is something
that you're
you would be having to cultivate
influence in your teams right now
yeah um like how have you gone about
ensuring that your team people
recruiters on your team that might be
doubting themselves right now
with how difficult things are um might
be
just overall finding it really difficult
and just
um you're having to play a role where
you're
just trying to encourage them in the
best way you can to make sure that they
carry through and get through this like
what would be
what's been your actual advice to your
team and it would be your actual advice
for people listening there people
yeah you know that might be going
through a slump right now or might be
going this is
[ __ ] horrible like yeah and and you
know what it is horrible like
anybody says that recruitment has been
really great for him the last three
months
yeah it's just like shy it's not true
it's been awful
yeah no i actually i think that's the
first thing like i think it's just to
recognize like
there is a global pandemic like there is
and there's nothing you can do about
that so
try not to be too too hard on yourself
first of all because
you've been thrown you know you're
dealing with something incredibly
challenging like none of us have ever
had to handle something like this before
so
it's not a reflection of you and your
ability it's a reflection of the
economic
you know state of affairs and what's
going on at the end of the day
the movement of people has been stopped
and that is what we do for a living so i
think the first thing is to just
recognize that and just need to know
what
has happened but obviously there are
ways around that there are ways of
making the most out of the situation so
what i've done with with my team is
firstly obviously getting them to accept
that it's not great no one's where they
want to be but it's not your fault
it's out of your control so we're doing
a lot of work at the moment on what
is and isn't out of your control you
can't control it don't worry about it
because
what's the point if you can control it
do something about it so
recruiters naturally are pretty social
people extroverts pretty externally
motivated
all that sort of stuff is gone at the
moment it's just the bare bones of the
job and it's a really really difficult
job to have even more so
than normal at the moment so that makes
it really really tough so day to day
we just keep talking a lot about goals
and celebrating mini
successes instead and we're not instead
but as well and putting more emphasis on
them and
in the daily closes we're sharing like
positive news we're celebrating
the small wins and just really
you know unity and collaboration is so
important especially because it's really
disjointed
at home so just trying to bring the team
together and leverage what we have got
to create as a positive
environment and atmosphere as we can and
i think just that reassurance when i'm
speaking to my team each morning setting
them up for the day
giving them really clear advice and
reassurance one amazing thing that's
come out of this
is video meetings so as you know i'm
massive on meetings and i've always
driven that with the team as well
but because they're all on video i can
attend like five meetings a day with the
team now whereas before i'd be like
right you've got me this day this month
yeah yeah
but now i'm doing like 30 40 meetings
and like
for them with them so that's been really
positive because from a training
perspective like
they all feel so much more confident
with meetings now and
we're literally doing like 16 17
meetings perhaps per month at the moment
like we're doing 120
odd a a month total like the amount of
pipeline that we must be generating from
that it's just incredible so
again just just focusing on stuff like
that and like focusing on the strategy
we've changed our strategy we're still
engineering we're still the core
disciplines but
rather than automotive in aerospace it's
very defense or building services
or food manufacturing you know so just
shifting what we're doing
yeah it's out of our comfort zone but
you know shifting to
to ensure that we're getting a return
and focusing a lot on leads as well
because the quicker wins
it's the quick streets market and you
know you're gonna get a quicker return
off a lead so we've just adjusted it a
little bit but
probably gone off on a tangent here in
terms of the team communication
yeah positive communication reassurance
talking about goals celebrating mini
wins trying to bring everyone together
as much as possible from a cultural
perspective and
you know just accepting that results
might not be what we were right now but
it's fine because we're going to get
through it we're doing the right things
and we've got a track record of success
and
they 100 providing the turning up each
day with the right attitude and working
hard they've got
100 backing from me and our business
to support them through this time yeah i
think that's amazing
um look so before we
finish yeah what is uh amy excited about
post what i know we're saying it's
probably gonna be there's gonna be a
while
on saturdays i can't wait where you
going
no live cases right now so i'm praying
that i can definitely go and definitely
not have to quarantine yeah so fair
enough
so look you've been in the industry for
a while
i guess just the final thing i'd love to
get your thoughts on before you finish
is like
what do you think is gonna stay
like no doubt our industry has been
sort of disrupted things have changed
you're working at home but all these
different things right
yeah but like in the next six to 12
months what what do you reckon
we'll end up staying and how do you
think that this whole experience will
positively affect
our industry do you think yeah sure so i
think
one thing we'll say is that there will
always be a need for recruitment
that's just a fact if you're working in
technical sectors where people are hard
to find
there will always be a need for your
services it might have slowed down
initially there might be more roadblocks
in the way in terms of people starting
jobs because of
remote working and things like that but
there will always always be a need and i
think you know you can't
by all the different technology
platforms and creative ways of doing
things you really can't quite be
just picking up the phone and speaking
to a client or picking up the phones
being to a candidate
and i think now more than ever like
that level of communication and customer
service is
is important because people will
remember how you handled
them now in the future and i think you
know
candidates calling you and you don't
work for them still taking the time to
have a chat with them and reassure them
as much as you can with a reason
obviously
and with clients who aren't hiring but
still
being consultative giving them advice
giving them industry news
like what are their competitors doing in
terms of onboarding people
inside all that stuff's really important
so yeah what will stay will be that
relationship
side customer service that that will
stick certain sectors will be busy than
others granted but
i think all that stuff despite
the changes will will still be there and
i think it should always just be a huge
emphasis for people in recruitment is
customer service and doing what you say
you're gonna do and being a reliable
person in the market that genuinely
wants to add value
and help and in terms of how we're going
to benefit from this
i mean we're going to be great at what
we do when things get better
aren't we like we're going to be so much
more mentally tough and resilient and
you know we're going to look back and
think you know if i can come through
that i can come through anything you
know one of the biggest challenges in
recruitment is resilience and why
most people don't work out is because
they just give up a little bit too soon
i think if you come out the other side
of this you'll be a better recruiter
a better manager about a business owner
and
when things get easier which they will
because this is temporary
you'll be better for it and you'll have
more clients
and more candidates and you'll hopefully
go on to be more successful and make
more money amazing
amy it's been a pleasure thank you for
having me